Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show at move the sticks is move the
sticks podcast is highly popular he's
also a radio voice for the Chargers with
our buddy Matt money Smith good to see
you how are you sir good to see but my
son who's 12 found my college helmet in
the closet the other day and was walking
around wearing it and I told me not
legal anymore he set that off and how
did you react he actually getting it off
so I think he'll never put it on yeah
you never put it on again huh you read
you red flag dad it's a red dot it's red
dotted yeah it's red dotted no long
can't be there anymore so Daniel
Jeremiah kind enough to join us here in
the Honda insider report brought to you
by our friends at the Honda Odyssey or
Honda Odyssey from a Honda we're haunted
we don't got four kids it's a great I
know that's the greatest alright so
let's get into it here you fluent in
Mayock to me if that they have green let
him alright yeah cuz we all know Gruden
has got that 10-year hundred million
dollar contract I'm sure he and Gruden
had a conversation about about processes
and things of that nature but for him to
say what he said yesterday spoke volumes
to me I wonder what you what you thought
when you saw that well first of all it
follows kind of the formula for teams
and that you want if you're gonna do the
good cop bad cop for lack of a better
phrase yes you want the good cop to be
downstairs with the player the bad cop
to be upstairs and so that's the role
Mike's gonna have to play which I think
he has no problem playing that role he's
very comfortable particular yes and so I
think that's the way it kind of had to
go down it was just a matter of whether
or not they were gonna press that button
and you know look if he's back out there
today
well it's know currently it needed to be
pressed there's no back out there
apparently it's a walkthrough that got
cancelled it's just everybody gets
together before they officially break
camp yeah right but at least he's in the
building is in the building but if he
doesn't show there's something called
failure to practice I mean he would be
opening himself up to if they do finally
hit the button even harder
yeah and decide that we're we're done
here yeah because they can't figure it
like what happens if week two he drops a
ball and he's he's got only two hundred
yards receiving in the first three games
no touchdowns he's gonna think it's the
helmet you know like this is not gonna
be over this is something that can
linger
deep into the most important part of the
year well to meet her to me and I go
back to what Mike said there's so many
different things you could take out of
what Mike said and you could really dig
into it but one thing that I heard one
word that I heard that I thought was
interesting he didn't say this team
meaning this team this year right now he
said I would like where this franchise
is headed which to me was a bigger
picture look at this thing so while
Antonio Brown might help us tomorrow and
the next day we're still gonna do what's
best for this franchise and where we're
headed so that to me says that hey this
thing needs to get needs to get done or
they are gonna look at some other
options that they might possess so what
else did you take from the main
competitor a couple other things the
we've exhausted all avenues of relief is
a great fantasy team name if you can fit
it as characters exhausted all Avenue or
as long or you make the avatars as a
sign Avenue relief Avenue okay there you
go okay nice I like exhausting avenues
exhausted but this is like a legitimate
poll question because that was that was
great but to me the favorite because I
think I've heard Mike say this before
end of story
no question no questions yeah but also
the thing to what it sounded like a
production meeting to me where we all
sit there and listen to my okay was when
he said there's 89 other guys on his
lost in their butts yeah he said he
would say that stuff all the time when
he was talking about a hard case in
somebody's locker room and how you got
to think about everybody in that locker
room I mean that was not a show that
literally felt like a 2012 pre-draft
meeting or a combine meeting today
that's what it sounded like to me it
sounded to me like we didn't show a
drill of a kid what we were talking
about another that kids busting his butt
exactly give him his moment give us a
moment
right but again to me that goes back to
whether you're focusing on you know the
the team short-term or the franchise
long-term this team's not won the Super
Bowl this year it's not breaking news so
the big picture what's best for this
franchise and Mike knows it's having all
these guys together going in the same
direction and not dealing with this kind
of stuff but can we already say this is
a terrible fit can we make this can we
make this decision right now
right here with all the dumpster fire
memes that you see here and that if they
do press this button which may be the
best thing for the franchise now that
they they went ahead and did this
maneuver but they wouldn't pay Khalil
Mack but they might have to pay this guy
in absurd amount of money even though
I'm sure they would do some form of
suspension to try and get out of
whatever guarantees they have to pay him
you got to believe they're hoping that
they can salvage this thing I mean if
you look at it right now it doesn't look
obviously not great Bob at this point no
matter hoping right that this thing can
get corrected I just keep coming back to
you know a couple points number one when
you look at the production of Antonio
Brown as recent as last year the level
of play you saw in the field and he was
made available to all 31 other teams and
the price that it fetched was a third
and a fifth round pick it told you there
was some concern about something like
this potentially happening and a team
that coughed up you know Antonio Brown
took a 21 million dollar cap hit yeah if
you get back this is between the five
yeah and you haven't heard a peep out of
Pittsburgh it seems like they're
enjoying camp this year so that was
classic addition by subtraction in their
view now he is it he is a great talent
and if they can get him in the right
frame of mind get him on the field
there's no doubt he'll help this version
of this Raider of game but man it just
it was like two different tracks free
agency with vantes perfect you just
brought in Richie incognito Antonio
Brown comes over then you look at who
they drafted high character work ethic
you know kind of program building
players right it almost seems like
you're on two different tracks there so
in order for this thing to go it's got
to figure out which track they want to
be on and I I think it eventually will
end up on that draft track but it was
curious how those two things were kind
of working against one another
Daniel Jeremiah here on the Rich Eisen
show you also provide the color
commentary on the radio broadcast for
the Los Angeles charges we had during
James here the other day and Chris and I
were both so impressed by just his laser
focused on ball that's what I want to
talk about this ball and then his Madden
rating those are the things which is
technically talking ball yeah him not
being there for how long is it possible
he's out for three months with a stress
from yeah you hear different things some
people say two months
people say three months I mean it's a
significant injury and how significant
to this defense is it well here's the
thing that he's he's to me he's the best
safety in the NFL right now you're not
going to be able to replace him
individually I think the bigger loss
haven't been around this team and in
traveling with this team as the is
surprisingly for such a young players
the leadership and the energy that he
brings you know you talked to Gus
Bradley last year early in the season he
was like DJ I'm blown away by this guy
not as just as what he can do on the
field but he's already a leader with so
many good veteran players on this
defense so they're gonna miss his
presence even more than they miss him as
a player which is which is crazy the one
thing I would say that gives charger
fans hope you look at this defensive
line and just being at the game
yesterday Jerry Tillery getting his
first opportunity he gets a sack Joey
Bosa is healthy he looks great melvin
ingram Chinon nuo su they got the
second-year defensive linemen just in
they don't haunt they are loaded with
front players so that's gonna take some
of the pressure off the back end and
then when you look at the schedule you
know like there's other good teams are
gonna play but the Chiefs that first
meeting is Mexico City I believes week
11 so they've got some time to see if
they get Melvin Gordon back we'll see if
they get their left tackle back and
Russell Koon and hopefully you get
Derwin James back at that point what do
you think about Gordon here what can you
tell me you know it's I just he's in a
weird spot he doesn't really have much
leverage and it's different from Zeke
situation when you look at what they
have behind him which is proven to be
two very capable backs in Austin Eckler
and Justin Jackson you look at a team
that's really quarterback driven it's
not quite as dependent on the running
back and you look at where the market is
I just I don't see the Chargers really
changing their stance here and I don't
know that he has a play so I look at
maybe I'm crazy I expect him that to
come in I think there's a chance you can
see him out there before we go on okay
you got the poll question over there
Chris Brocklin before we move forward
here in the Honda inside report yes so
we we did this two weeks ago let's run
it back most likely to play week one
mostly I could have a weak one Melvin
Gordon Zico Elliott Antonio Brown and
last two weeks ago who won that poll
Antonio Brown one going away two weeks
ago I would agree with that still today
yeah I would probably I think there's a
good chance we see all three of them
week one I do it you know what I know
man Tony Pollard he looked great he
looked he looked really good but this is
I mean I saw I think half the Rams team
didn't get on the airplane to go over
there so why you got to be able to rein
that in a little bit now he looks great
he's not zq elliot and that team is
running back dependent more so than the
Chargers would be so I still think
there's more leverage with Zeke Elliot
and you know I think the Dallas Cowboys
at this point time where this team is
ready to win right now can you see Jerry
Jones saying guys I'm really worried
about the salary cap three years from
now let's hold firm I just I don't see
that now I don't see it either I just
don't know you know I mean he made an
analogy about how you know if you're in
an accident and you have your hand cut
off I missed this
did you see the hole yeah he's talking
about how he's in an accident if your
hands cut off and you're bleeding
profusely and some people will just
panic and run into the woods to try and
find help right away but if you've been
in an accident like this before you just
hold onto and wait for help to arrive
that was his analogy with these holdouts
basically saying he's waiting for help
to arrive with the playing season to
provide the leverage that he needs on
these players and my thought was well
why don't you just leave early avoid the
traffic and the accident entirely just
like the Eagles do yeah you know yeah
that's the hope I don't understand why
the Cowboys wait I mean you spent time
in front office's why do teams wait to
make these maneuvers the interesting
thing I would say in especially
comparing with the cow with the Eagles
thing the quarterback market has proven
that's climbing it's only going to
continue to climb so today's deal is
gonna be perceived as a bargain next
year where as the running back market is
flat and stale so there's a little bit
of a vibe of man if I if I throw this
number out here this we might not see
this number by another back ever you
know that's the feeling that you get
right now is it to markets go in an
opposite direction so you don't want to
set one that's never gonna get broken a
few more minutes left with Daniel
Jeremiah here in the Rich Eisen show
what have we gleaned from the rookie
quarterbacks over the first couple weeks
of the preseason do you think anything
well I think you're gleaning a lot about
what's around him
first of all Daniel Jones is you know
and visited with him several times
through the process you know at the pro
day the Senior Bowl the combine visiting
with him in New York I've never seen him
this comfortable and I think this is a
great environment most times you go to
New York makes you uncomfortable with
Eli established there and no pressure on
him to play right now I think the best
thing for his development and I think
you're seeing it really takes strides
and grow in the position so that's been
fun to watch Kyler Murray I haven't seen
him in person and then watch the tape
even from this last week they're not
good up front and I don't know you know
why they have some good players on the
perimeter they're gonna see a lot of
press man coverage and people are just
gonna send bodies at him and it's gonna
be an adjustment yeah I mean we saw him
go six for six in his first drive down
check okay shut down and then we saw
this past week where he looked he took a
sack you try to avoid the hit let's put
it this way
took his safety by trying to avoid the
head and then we've seen obviously a bit
of a struggle in the trust game by
Dwayne Haskins and then a remarkably
beautiful dime on a law I mean just up
what it looked like a go pattern
something like that beautiful balls
inside it was a girl rough from the
inside oh my gosh and he just it's like
he flicked his wrists and it went 50
yards and it went right in the hands
have wearing how to go he had yeah that
was amazing so everybody was kind of
crushing him for the picks in the first
game I went back and watched that game
right on tape first of all I didn't
think I think you could make a strong
case both those picks there was some
shared blame it wasn't just him right
and he made two or three throws in that
first week that were better throws than
any of the other rookie quarterbacks
made so in terms of degree of difficulty
hole shot versus cover - I mean just
big-time big-time throws so what might
take a little while for it all to come
together but if you're talking about
sealing man if you're a [ __ ] family
you gotta be pretty excited yeah and and
then what about Lamar Jackson I'm very
high in the Ravens I'm like the only guy
I think out there that's saying it's
their division to lose yeah he you know
he's hardly run the ball I think he's
gonna run his head off once the season
does begin yeah
I'd like to unlike what the rate you're
very obviously very close to that
organization having spent some time
there what do you make of the Ravens
Connor was talking
to remember their personnel department
the other day and I said hey most give
me a breakout player for the team and
usually you're kind of looking for
somebody that's not on the radar he goes
Lamar Jackson I go yeah that's not fair
you can't say Lamar Jackson as a
breakout player we saw him last year
right he's like he's so much better this
year than what we saw last year so it's
gonna be fun I think so too right by the
way they have joint practices with the
Eagles this week ok so that will be a
great test for both those teams very
talented what do you mean well you're
gonna see line of scrimmage those are
two of the better teams on both sides
they're going against each other so
these joint practice to me infinitely
more entertaining than the preseason
well maybe that's where we're going
right
fewer preseason taking so long let's do
it well the collective bargain agreement
that might also include later on we'll
talk about it in the news update more
playoff games or something like that
before I let you go college football
what do you what do you what are you
seeing on tape all ready for our next
evaluation season that we might also see
play out from important games coming up
this weekend it's gonna be fun I mean
this weekend we got Miami and Florida I
was watching a Florida corner named CJ
Henderson who's outstanding the corner
group last year and the draft wasn't
great this year it's really good he's
one of the ones that you watch there
they got quarterman as a linebacker from
Miami's a fun player so I'm looking
forward to that and then Khalil Tate get
to see him I know I think it's a 730
West Coast game at in Hawaii to see if
he's you know getting more comfortable
in that Kevin Sumlin system and then
rich we're gonna have to Otunga vile
Oahu's fun to watch Justin Herbert's
gonna be fun to watch Georgia would
shake from I'm so fired up for college
football I'm glad it's here Michigan
with Jake Patterson Shay Patterson by
the way I reached out to a bunch of
people getting these quarterbacks try
and line them up before the season
starts yeah everybody says shake
Patterson they all like his ability
they're all they're all bullish on his
ability they want to learn more about
the kid so yeah I have to lean on you
with your Michigan high just like
throwing that out there who's the app
app state quarterback trying to fill
your shoes oh no he's pretty good he's
16 good almost beat Penn State he's back
so we'll see we got North Carolina week
three and if they beat them Bucky Brooks
will never hear the end of it that's the
only team I care about the whole year
just win that one all right before I let
you go the flat flash player give me
somebody that's flashed right here on
the first two
makes the preseason that you really buy
into it like what we've seen so far can
be bought and sold in NFL fantasy or
reality stores near you well I mean look
I feel like I've been driving the same
darn 'old bus and called you last year
when that first game popped and him he's
he's comfortable and confident he looks
good I'd know preseason is a liar that's
my belief but it started not to get
excited if you're watching him play and
Le'Veon Bell hasn't even played it down
yet and I've heard he looks great
in camp I know a couple people I know
you did don't scare me like that anymore
okay
don't Scott come on and I have am I
going anywhere well I mean I'm glad no
cuz you know I'm making all the fun max
having man it looks awfully inviting
yeah oh gosh yeah Mayock is uh I'm glad
you did you exhaust all avenues of
opportunity no I know very good this is
gonna be my fantasy name right exactly
exhausting all avenues by the way that's
it exhausting all avenues pretty good
and then and then you get beaten by Drew
Rosenhaus his team he has a little
booklet like okay receiver drama and he
has flips to that page get the
manuscript out and go I'm telling you
something that is manufactured by the
player that can be fixed by the player
is nothing compared to what we'll talk
about with Joe Banner in the next hour
he's gonna have some stories for it I
bet 844 204 rich number two doubt for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app